[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti se vi chiedessi
come siete arrivati in questa sala
molto probabilmente mi diresti a piedi
camminare infatti una delle attività
principali della nostra vita quotidiana
ed è da noi usata per molte molte molte
cose per esempio
incontrare altre persone
recarsi al lavoro
visitare nuovi luoghi e nuovi posti è
l'attività che noi utilizziamo per
riempire e per deambulare nello spazio
ma è anche molto spesso al centro della
nostra vita sociale
ora proviamo tutti a pensare per un
attimo la condizione di persone che
hanno difficoltà a camminare persone per
cui non è così semplice salire su questo
palco come ho fatto io adesso magari per
molti di voi arrivare qui oggi
ecco probabilmente per queste persone
la difficoltà del cammino è il primo
pensiero che hanno quando salgono quando
scendono dal letto
persone come valentina che avete visto
in questo video ci scrivono e ci
chiamano ogni giorno chiedendoci di
aiutarli a camminare meglio di riuscire
a vincere le loro piccole sfide
quotidiane
facendolo con le proprie gambe
da ingegnere quale sono credo che la
nostra funzione sia quella di migliorare
la vita delle persone
è per questo che ho dedicato gli ultimi
anni della mia della mia vita e della
mia carriera a pensare a studiare come
camminano le persone e cosa possiamo
costruire per permettere a loro di
camminare meglio
questo è l'impatto che abbiamo avuto
nella vita di valentina grazie al
dispositivo che ho ideato e realizzato e
realizzato io e che oggi sta facendo
camminare meglio centinaia di persone
il dispositivo
è un dispositivo che ha sostanzialmente
due particolarità che lo rendono unico
nel proprio genere
la prima è che è un dispositivo
totalmente passivo passivo significa che
abbiamo eliminato ogni forma di sensore
elettronica batterie motore il
dispositivo immagazzina l'energia che
noi normalmente generiamo durante il
cammino
nello specifico nella prima fase del
ciclo del passo quando atterriamo col
piede al suolo e portiamo la gamba
indietro e la restituisce alla persona
nella seconda fase del ciclo del passo
aiutando i flessori che sono appunto i
muscoli anteriori della coscia a portare
la gamba in avanti in questo modo le
persone riescono a camminare facendo
meno fatica
utilizzando meno energia e riescono a
camminare per tratti più lunghi appunto
stancandosi meno la seconda
particolarità è che il dispositivo è
sostanzialmente composto di tessuti e
realizzato così in modo confortevole e
funzionale è unito alla particolarità
precedente fa sì che sia molto molto
leggero
siamo recentemente stati definiti come
gli ideatori dell'esoscheletro più
leggero al mondo
quando
realizzò
risultati come quello che avete visto
quando riusciamo col mio gruppo aiutare
la signora valentina a camminare meglio
mi sento di avere vinto mi sento che
sono riuscito ad avere un impatto
positivo e reale nella vita di persone
che faticano tutti i giorni a camminare
nel mettere insieme però questa
presentazione di oggi al ted
mi sono chiesto cosa significhi
effettivamente vincere
per quella che è la mia storia personale
credo che il significato reale di
vincere sia in realtà imparare a perdere
imparare quindi a gestire a sopportare a
non farsi troppo abbattere da situazioni
negative quando ci siamo delineati un
percorso e abbiamo appunto un obiettivo
da raggiungere
tutte le volte in cui succede quello che
noi non vorremmo che succedesse queste
sono sconfitte fare pace con se stessi e
con le sconfitte e capire che sono parte
naturale del percorso e senza queste non
sarebbe possibile poter ottenere
risultati di tipo diverso nel 2017
lavoravo a harvard come ricercatore ed
ero molto soddisfatto è riuscito ad
arrivare in un'università prestigiosa
avevo un gruppo di ricerca dove facevo
quello che mi piaceva e mi divertivo
ciononostante ho deciso a 35 anni di
lasciare tutto di tornare a padova e di
ricominciare da zero
francamente penso che siano più le volte
che ho perso che quelle che ho vinto se
penso al numero di persone con cui ho
parlato
investitori nel momento in cui sta
andando a fondare un'azienda che non
hanno creduto nell'idea che non hanno
voluto investire noi
scienziati ingegneri collaboratori che
non sono venuti a lavorare del mio team
ho che hanno pensato che l'idea non
fosse buona e il dispositivo non
funzionava quindi ho imparato a far a
far pace e andare d'accordo con la
sconfitta a perdere molte volte per
continuare quello che era ed è e che
continua a essere il mio obiettivo
ovvero cercare di far camminare meglio
un milione di persone
ecco quindi questo volevo portare a voi
oggi questa esperienza questa storia
personale di sconfitte che sono
necessarie per poter poi ottenere anche
alcune vittorie come quella che abbiamo
della signora valentina e soprattutto
ricordare che qualsiasi sia il percorso
qualsiasi sia l'obiettivo che avete
scelto questo sarà necessario farlo un
passo alla volta
basta